in the literary world names don't get
much bigger than John Grisham's the
best-selling author is responsible for
writing some of the most popular legal
thrillers of the past 30 years including
a time to kill the firm and the Pelican
brief just to name a few
in 2006 he wrote his first nonfiction
book the innocent man murder and
injustice in a small town it focuses on
the murders of two women in Oklahoma the
four men who were convicted and the
questions raised over their guilt now
Netflix has turned the book into a
six-part original documentary series of
the same name it premieres on December
14th here's a sample in small towns like
ADA the prosecutors and the police are
under enormous pressure winning means
justice winning means everything and
along the way if the truth gets blurred
or forgotten or twisted or manipulated
that's too bad
and that's how we get wrongful
convictions that's how you get Ron
Williamson Dennis Fritz Tommy Ward and
Carla Fontana and that's what happens so
often in in criminal prosecutions it's
all about winning and john christian
joins us here in the studio John good
morning welcome you have said that if
you had written begin us at man as a
novel people wouldn't have believed it
why is that it's too incredible to
believe it's too you can't believe the
system can break down so badly and and
so many things can go wrong and which is
true with most wrongful conviction cases
there's a complete breakdown in the
police investigation the prosecution one
mistake after another one injustice
after another and I can't create that
stuff in fiction tell us about these two
crimes what was so unbelievable well
over to two murders in the small town in
Oklahoma about 18 months apart and both
the crimes were unsolved and the police
struggle with them for a long time and
the first crime the first murder Debbie
sue Carter the eventual killer
was the last man seen alive with the
victim but for some reason the police
chose not to investigate him didn't for
a long time they finally settled on two
other guys Ron Williams and Dennis Fritz
and they were eventually convicted and
sent to prison and Ron Williamson came
within 5 days of being executed for
murder he had nothing to do with John
what led you to this story I wasn't
looking for another story when I saw
this one yeah Ron died in 19 and 2004
he'd been out for five years
I saw his obituary in The New York Times
and I was taken with it it was a
fantastic story
he was the first round draft pick of the
Oakland A's in 1972 small town hero
great baseball player in his little
section of Oklahoma people thought he
was the next Mickey Mantle and he did
too he had a big ego great player didn't
work out went back to his small town of
Ada and started showing signs of mental
illness and became kind of the town
drunk or whatever and so the police pin
this murder on him and he was almost
executed you know you write them the
book and then it gets to this Netflix
documentary in the series I'm curious
what it was or what it is that you're
able to do with this now that you
couldn't do with the book what was the
reasoning behind it well first of all I
had almost nothing to do with the movie
even though I'm the executive producer
whatever that means
I've had like nine or ten movies made I
don't get nearly right I just I read the
screenplay I talked about the idea
talked to the director meet the people
making the movie but I don't make movies
I don't know how to make movies I don't
want to learn that's somebody else's
things I stayed away from it but we
always deal with good people who are you
know know what they're doing in this
case it's a young director named clay
twill who's a real rock star in the
documentary film world and he's also
from my town of Charlottesville Virginia
and then so that was not important but I
said go with it he got a great idea for
it he they wrote a great script and I
said let's do it Netflix he jumped
behind it and he put up the money and
here we are
it certainly reaches a different
audience we hope so we hope that reaches
a big audience let's go ahead there were
some taped confessions involved with
these cases why do you think these four
men were innocent in the first murder
Ron Williamson
spritzer really weren't confessions you
know those guys were convicted and
exonerated by DNA in a second murder of
Denise hare way two young men confessed
and the confessions are bogus the false
confessions they were they came about
because of abusive interrogations by the
police and then the the confessions
match nothing to do with with the with
the crime scene okay but those guys are
still in prison 33 years later that
murder has not been solved okay
in my opinion okay in the opinion of a
lot of people watch the documentary and
you'll believe it too that they got the
wrong guys is there some hope then that
this will lead to possibly getting them
exonerated and finding the real murderer
oh where nurse always helps both of
those guys are still fighting in court
they have lawyers the Innocence Project
is trying to help them but it's been 33
years you mentioned the Innocence
Project something you're personally
involved with what sort of work are they
doing here well I'm on the board I build
a board since the book was published
when the book came out in 2006 they
asked me to join the board and I've been
on my board since then and I really
enjoy this work I mean I do I've written
about wrongful config convictions
exonerations I've written about the
death penalty it's kind of what I enjoy
writing about obviously but the
Innocence Project here in New York we we
work to get innocent people out of
prison
we have about 365 DNA exonerations in
the past 25 years
Oh Ronnie and Dennis were two of them in
1999 and we work every day with a you
know a big staff that's not quite big
enough because there are a lot of
potential clients out there a lot of
innocent people in prison it takes just
one voice and one person to help it
takes a it takes a good good legal team
yeah thank you so much job and again the
series is called the innocent man it
will be available on Netflix December
14th